les deux présidents les républicains des
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine réunis au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en ce début
d'année une cérémonie de voeux en commun
pour des discours très politique dans la
ligne de mire de pierre bédier et
patrick devedjan le gouvernement et son
grand débat national
ces débats je le crains vous aurez
jouiront comme chaîne d'information
continue et les plus extrêmes trouveront
de toute façon à mettre en scène et lui
contentement du peuple et les deux
présidents de demander plus de liberté
pour la nouvelle année liberté notamment
de poursuivre le rapprochement de leur
département afin d'obtenir la validation
du projet de fusion nous avons rempli
toutes les obligations légales qui
permettent la fusion donc le
gouvernement est mal venu de considérer
ou de déclarer qu'il y a trop de
collectivités locales que ceux-ci
génèrent des coûts nous nous proposons
au contraire de fusionner et nous avons
répondu à toutes les obligations légales
pour ça et le gouvernement fait la
sourde oreille
je veux dire à l'état qu'il n'a pas le
monopole de l'intérêt général que nous
partageons l'état et les collectivités
ce souci de l'intérêt général et qu'il
faut sortir de ce système très archaïque
d'un état centralisateur neta qui décide
de tout parce qu'en l'état décide de
tout rien ne marche
un seul mot d'ordre donc au cours de
cette soirée décentralisation pad
annonce de nouveaux projets en revanche
pour le moment yvelines et
hauts-de-seine partage notamment un
service de voirie ou encore
d'archéologie et d'adoption